to bring to the table the fact that
numbers don't speak the whole answer is
questions is that what you're saying
because that's what you're in playing no
I'm not implying I'm just because I want
people to understand that
generalizations do not work because in
every single statistic there's more
specifications within it the same way
that the same way that we're saying
women nowadays do this women nowadays
that which women which numbers we are
modern women but I'm a modern woman but
a lot of the things we do we do know the
reasons because they tell you why they
filed for divorce and the number one is
financial and one of the number one
reasons because one of the number one
reasons that women leave is they start
to out earn their husband and you're
right maybe he's not providing but
that's pretty freaking selfish when you
have a child because if you have
children it's not about you it's about
your kids happiness and that's the
problem is I'll have single mother after
single mother not you guys personally
again but on my show where they'll say
oh I left because I wasn't happy where I
left because and that's the problem with
modern women is it's me me me me me
before anybody else and when we make
poor decisions there's always an excuse
and that's why you know what that's
shitty we should probably be better
when does the man's happiness come into
a relationship for a woman because when
as men what we hear when it when we hear
women speak a lot like as Pearl does
this show four four times a week I I
speak to women all the time I do this
show right and a lot of the time when we
listen to women speak it's all me me me
and it's like well
when does your man's happiness come into
the equation when do you say okay cool
it's not about me and it's actually
about me trying to make somebody else
happy because you have to understand men
are actually men have an inbuilt thing
when they get a woman to make them happy
it's inbuilt do you know I mean like
when men get with the woman's that old
you know what I want to take her there
and this makes her happy and this she
likes this women don't tend to have that
they tend to say make me happy actually
I've done things just as things for my
all the time like even like let's say he
just finished the competition because he
does he does parkour in America he does
Park all over the world okay
um we've just finished and stuff and
then he came back to the UK I surprised
him with a picnic and stuff like that
like I do think what he wants I don't
think it's okay to generalize is that
okay can I can I have a question and is
it picnics would you say that's more
something men would like or women would
like I think
picnic is actually I know he loves that
he does think he even said it to me like
before because we broke up once and he
said to me I I the only reason why I
actually did picnic because he
specifically said to me I just want you
to be at least like this kind of girl
that kind of you know go to pick with me
read books you know have some fruits all
these cute things together so that's
actually the reason why I took him to
picnic because he said so well I think a
lot of the time men cap in relationships
right I think a lot of the time men say
the things that they think women want to
hear but then
this is a personal thing I don't know
you personally but like every time and
I've talked to so many women every time
a girl does something for a guy it
always is on the side of what girls
would like what goes with like I'm sorry
let me okay again I do this four times a
week and I ask a lot of the same
questions four times a week so this
isn't you know let me let me let me let
me finish it you can go so I asked the
same question four times a week for six
months do you know how many people I've
talked to in six months so but I'm
saying every time I ask a girl this
question it is always something that the
woman would want and never say did you
buy him one oh my God and I'm not saying
every single woman but I'm saying to me
that indicates something about women as
a whole yeah hang on did you buy him
hang on did you buy him tickets for his
favorite football team let me tell you I
brought him his favorite shoes
me I've never generally let me say not
never generally when women say they've
done something for their man right yeah
I'm saying a man likes that like he
likes picnics and walks in the park no
you don't men like you know men like
track days they want to race a Ferrari
like they want to go and play football
as well because he wanted to do that and
I totally agreed I was like okay we went
and he does parkour and I said okay
let's go out and train parkour too and
it sounds like an active dude yeah he's
active and I really like that he's very
ambitious he's got a lot to offer and I
know I do have to because as what I said
every time I go to him visit him I cook
for him I clean for him I do things that
he loves and he does the same thing to
me too and I think it should be like
that in a relationship I think if you're
listening to your man then it's easy
like for me I feel like I have a lot of
feminine energy but at the same time
it's easy for me to do nice things for
my man so for example if we're out
walking and there's something in the
shop that he sees and he's like oh
that's really nice then I remember that
but I also want the same thing though
yeah but you see the problem the problem
with modern females is let's say they do
something for a man
a majority of cases they do something
because they expect something so let me
give you example let's say you gave him
Tommy for his birthday something big and
expensive and he just gives you a
birthday card majority of the time the
woman is going to be like I gave you
this and it cost me this and this is
what you're giving me so how would you
feel as a man if you also gave some
expensive back to your girl
answer the question how would you feel
what how would you feel you had my
questions repeat the question repeat the
question it makes sense sorry repeat the
question you didn't allow me to speak
sir I said how would you feel if you
brought your girl some 20 grand back or
anything that is so expensive and then
she just gave you a card how would you
feel wait let me answer the questions
goodness gracious all right number one I
would never do that [__] number two
number two let's say let's say you did
that yeah hey well major of the time
guys that do do that is like the simps
but let's say you do that because your
woman is treating you nice nurturing
submissive woman you do that in an
intention because she deserves she
earned that [__] so even if she gives
you a card you don't give a [__] you
don't give a damn because you don't
expect that [__] back you just you just
expect well and and matter you're used
to it you guys take girls on nice dates
all the time
if you expect sex then you're a
misogynist me ask you a question then
you work hard nine to five you wake up
maybe six a.m because you're also
commuting you work your ass off yeah you
do all of this to provide your woman
with a home right and your woman will
not even cook for you give you a massage
she won't even help you do anything with
your shirt before you go to work she's
just there enjoying life she don't care
about what you do for she doesn't show
right she won't be there exactly so how
is it that you expect a woman yeah to do
things for men and then the men don't
don't even reciprocate it's not about
things what do you mean the reciprocate
I don't I don't expect women no no
thanks for men that don't reciprocate I
expect women to pick good men exactly
and that's the same way that men should
pick good women I agree and that's why I
say there's difference between men and
boys and girls and women men and women
yes men and girls yeah the problem the
problem is that modern women the
majority of modern women are good wives
and I can tell you this how many how
many of you are virgins yeah well you
don't you don't want to be a president
okay okay this is like the first one all
of my shows how many how many of you
have a cookbook I don't need as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible